We are pleased to announce
Vox Tech Angelic Security is coming soon.
Trust us with your safety.
Fire to put out upstairs.
Burn it like the witches who wore it. Oh, velvet.
And, uh, what's got him so out of sorts today?
Uh. What are you doing, Val?
You're not going over there.
That slippery twink is going to remember who owns him.
I'm gonna fuck everyone in that rancid shithole,
I swear to god.
Ha, ha. Think about it. Uh,
fuck it up, right?
Do nothing. Great idea.
Now, that's why the shoot someone. Well,
the radio demon is there.
What did you just say?
You heard me. And he is with Lucifer's daughter.
And that wasn't the first fucking thing you told me.
Hey, Kelly, honest. There is your kink.
Fox. Fox.
That's the team.
You old tiny prick.
I'll show you suffering. Oh,
the TV is buffering.
I'll destroy you if he don't kill you.
Go ahead and do it yourself. You